let me just read this request that I got
here from this gentleman so uh I put it
in the description it says I've become
stagnant stagnant in my current life uh
set up and looking for a second home to
help support my growth demand I'm 34.
lived in the US most of my life moved to
Thailand two years ago have enjoyed it
thoroughly but I desire a new Mountain
climb
it's always that way when you're when
you're chasing Excellence it's it's the
climb to the top that you enjoy once you
get to the top it's like oh look there's
another Mountain over there let's go
over and check that out
um that's what that's what winners do
that's what that's what playing the win
is all about
you're going to say I'm worth eight
figures my business is remote single no
kids five foot eleven handsome and speak
English and a bit of Spanish
since Thailand is easy mode have dated
pageant girls models Etc considering
somewhere in Europe so cities and
demographics are more polished and
elegant also have much more competitive
environments uh plan on building a
family in five years or so he's 34 so I
got 39 40. uh what do you think I should
plant my second flag to complement
southeast Asia thank you for everything
all right
um so where can we begin with this one
so let's turn down this uh
um
Where Do We Begin let's let's just kind
of think this one through because I was
just literally in Sardinia uh which is
an island South of I think it's Corsica
and west of the boot in the football if
you're looking at the map
um
I've
put myself kind of in a similar
situation where I'm looking at I mean
I've talked about this before many times
so been around for a while you've heard
me say this
um I'm looking to get a lot of Canada
and get myself a supplement place for
taxes our reasonable and men are treated
better
masculinity is respected and admired so
I get the whole movement to fight
better
uh Thailand is I get lots of positive
feedback for Thailand I had Tony huge on
uh Plain England podcast
before I left it was about three or four
weeks ago and he's got some crazy
stories man that guy
um you know he was a lawyer in
California and he basically schooled his
uh Law Firm went over to Thailand and he
hasn't left since you know he's on this
like um life projects where game to
create a harem of women and uh you know
have a bunch of babies and he's got some
friends there he's got a real
interesting stories all into like
bodybuilding chemistry and biohacking
stuff like that you can go check that
out on the on the um entrepreneurs
channel uh but he was
um he wasn't what I expected I didn't
know that he was into certain things I.E
like ladyboys so I thought that was that
was interesting but our friend here is
asking the question like where in Europe
would you set his second flag to
complement southeast Asia and I get this
you know thrown at me a lot man like
where do you go like you know what would
you do rich like what's your what's your
plan what's your angle and I think the
questions that you got to be asking
yourself are probably things along the
lines of
what do you like first of all what are
your tolerances for
um taxes and how the state is going to
treat you and extract wealth from you
because let's be honest that's all taxes
are I mean you know when you get to the
nitty-gritty of it you start to
understand it's like you know why do we
pay so much in the way of taxes in
countries like Canada for example when
they can print unlimited money right
um
so we can go down some really deep that
[__] crazy rabbit holes with tin foil
hats but that's that's one of the first
questions I'm going to be asking is
where can I set up this flag where
um if I'm gonna live there and that's
probably gonna be one of the permanent
places that I spend time at
um but I structure my life in such a way
that I'm not allowing the state to steal
my wealth for me
um simple question what do you like do
you like beaches you like mountains you
like mountains mountains and beaches you
like cold weather do you like warm
weather do you like skiing do you like
uh damp weather do you like humid
weather dry heat a lot of questions that
you want to ask that I would have to
answer for myself when I make my own
decision but yours is probably going to
be different for me so there's some
things that I would ask there as far as
climate uh culinary uh you know food
like what is a food like where you live
because there's some countries like if
we're being honest and don't have the
greatest Cuisine that's kind of [__]
there's other countries that have really
really good food like if you go to the
Mediterranean area you'll find that
um I think the top two rated countries
as far as uh
Italy and Greece I found the food in
Italy amazing really good the coffee the
coffee there spoiled me I can't even
drink this [__] over here anymore now
it's like I'm I'm [__] ruined I have
to go get one of these you know
expensive stainless steel machines that
you know pop all this stuff and you know
you get those nice americanos or
espressos but
um drinking coffee there for like two
and a half weeks it's like I'm ruined
but I I can't drink the stuff that they
sell here anymore it's just Nat's piss
um so there's things to contemplate you
know when it comes to Lifestyle like
what do you like to eat what do you like
to drink you know does that does that
matter to you you know to me I really
like kind of training food especially
Italian and Greek food I'm probably more
so inclined to enjoy you know Greek four
food more than Italian food that's just
my palette that's what I like it's kind
of what I grew up on too so there's that
um this guy's obviously single and he's
looking to start a family in five years
or so so the other questions I'd be
asking is what women do you like
um now women are mobile like you can
pick up a woman from one country that
you like and move her to another country
that you like to have lived in
entirely plausible but I think you want
to plant yourself in a place where
you're going to get the maximum exposure
to the kind of gals that
um
you know blow your hair back so you'd be
wanting to ask yourself questions like
you know are these kind of tricks that I
want to deal with
um more specifically for this guy
because he's planning on building a
family is
um are these kind of women that
um I can see as my children's Mother uh
but I want to put some babies in so
that's a really important one too
um I don't know
how much that matters to him he looks
like he's um North American so he gave
me his link to his social media I'm not
going to share it obviously but he's
exactly as he purports you know a
successful entrepreneur holds up to the
public on social media that he lives an
interesting life
um
makes good money you know from what I
can tell from his lifestyle he's a
handsome fit guy you know like as he
describes I'm sure he'll he'll do just
fine the easy mode that you experience
in Southeast Asia probably won't be the
same as what you're going to experience
in Eastern Europe
um it's gonna be a little bit more
competitive obviously and depending on
where you're going in Eastern Europe you
might have to deal with
um some more masculine guys than what
you've dealt with or competed against in
the past I.E
lots of strong virtuous masculine
Eastern European dudes Uh Russian dudes
they don't like you can't push these
guys around man like they like they're
they're solid casts if you know what I'm
saying
um so culture culture and competition is
probably something that you want to look
at too so we covered climate food taxes
women those would be the main things I
think that hobbies and interests should
probably matter too
[Music]
um
I'm not gonna put this
I I really have grown to have
more and more of a distaste for shitty
climates
as I've gotten older simply because you
don't necessarily need to be there and
if you don't need to be there then why
are you there you know basically is a
question that I'm asking myself right
um which is part of the reason why I'm
trying to get out of this uh train wreck
that's um you know we live in here
anyway so those are a lot of things to
contemplate and you know it gets to the
point of like what would I do you know
or where do you think I should plant
that second flag
if it was me I'd set up tax residency in
a country
that is friendly
that you don't have to spend a lot of
time in uh there's different places you
can do that there's places in the
Caribbean uh Cayman Islands Barbados has
a
a plan where you only have to be there
basically for like one day a year
um Dubai obviously has their strategy
but Dubai is intolerable
um in the hotter Seasons like most guys
that I know that live there for tax
reasons they you know they only are
there for a short period of time bug out
um but you can still set up your company
and your income and your lifestyle so
that you're not paying anything in taxes
um so those would be the places to
incorporate as far as
um your your financial life because your
ass doesn't need to be where sorry your
assets don't need to be where your ass
is right like you can set up your assets
in a place like you buy which is Central
you know to all of that for example to
Asia and to Eastern Europe and your ass
can be in Poland uh Latvia you know
wherever you want to plant it you know
at the end of the day
um so find what works for you uh for me
it's warm weather it's access to
mountains it's access to Great roads uh
fast cars
um those are the kind of things that I
would I would see myself enjoy probably
um you know because oceans uh sailboats
or Islands
um so I'd be looking around obviously
Mediterranean for stuff like that those
would be
high points that I would evaluate and
consider if that if that helps so
hopefully that makes some sense it's
it's a
you know it's a puzzle with a lot of
pieces it's no go here and do this you
know cut and dry cookie cutter thing and
let's be honest countries are a lot like
women
they reserve the right to change their
mind at any given time about how they're
going to treat you or how they feel
about you you might receive a strong
invitation or have a strong calling to a
certain country or certain region and 10
years down the road uh leadership
changes maybe there's military coup uh
tax laws aren't as favorable they might
become hostile there's countries that
have turned from Pleasant and
comfortable and quiet to war zones
there's countries that have
changed leadership and decided to take
assets from expats
um you know like over time their laws
and regulations change so I don't think
any one place would be a good idea but
to this guy's point like this is a
second flag so this is place number two
for them you'd want more than one
passport you probably want access to
more than just one country so that you
can maneuver if things do change so
there's also that to consider because
over time again like women countries
deserve the right to change their mind
at any given time and 10 years down the
road what you thought was good may not
be good you know I can say that for
Canada right like my parents came here
when I was young I was born in the UK
and this was the place to go right it
was either here or the states and they
they came here mostly because my mom's
uh mother so my uh yeah yeah you know
which is a Greek term for grandmother uh
lived here
so of course
um you know she persuaded my dad because
that's what men have always been told to
do like you know you do what's right uh
happy wife happy life blah blah all that
sort of stuff and they came to Canada
um this is not the same place that
I was a child in that I grew up in a lot
of things have changed the wokeness and
rainbows the alphabet crowd the pronouns
uh tax rates have gone through the roof
um your personal freedoms have been
stripped and robbed from you in all
areas of life you know I'm not just
talking about scandemic stuff or the
forceful jobs and
um like even laws for pleasurable things
that we always enjoyed when we were kids
like driving fast cars uh you know
they've calmed down in areas so hard
that whenever we do rallies now we don't
even do the mechanic we go down the
states because one I mean the roads are
very good in the Appalachian Trail and
two uh the laws aren't quite as hostile
in certain States Virginia's a bit of
pain in the ass but you know it's all
these things that have changed over time
so you you can't just say you know this
is a spot and it's got to be the spot
going forward that can change and it
probably will change for a lot of people
so uh you know keep that in mind I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supper element line books
and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out